Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible].
Ease your eyes upon the simulation from our previous episode,
that showcases a high viscosity material. That is honey.
The fact that honey is viscous means that it is a material that is highly
resistant against defamation. In simpler words, if we can simulate viscosity,
well, we can engage in a favorite pastimes of the computer graphics researcher,
or in other words, take some of these letters, throw them around,
watch them slowly lose their previous shapes.
And then of course destroy them in a spectacular manner.
I love making simulations like this. And when I do,
I want to see a lot of detail,
which unfortunately means that I also have to run the simulations for a long
time.
So when I saw that this new technique promises to compute these about four
times faster, it really grabbed my attention.
Here is a visual demonstration of such a speed difference.
So four times you'll say that sounds fantastic,
but what's the catch here.
This kind of speed up usually comes with cutting corners.
So let's test the might of this new method through three examples of
increasing difficulty experiment. Number one,
here is the regular simulation and here is the new technique.
So let's see the quality differences one more time.
Well, I don't see any,
do you four times faster with no degradation in
quality? Hmm. So far so good.
So now let's give it a harder example, experiment. Number two,
varying viscosities and temperatures. In other words,
let's give this bunny a hot shower. That was beautiful.
And our question is again,
how close is this to the slow reference simulation? Wow,
this is really close.
I have to look carefully to even have a fighting chance in finding a difference
check Mark. And I also wonder,
can he deal with extremely detailed simulations and now hold onto your
papers for experiment. Number three,
dropping a viscose bunny on thin wires,
and just look at the remnants of the poor bunny stuck in there,
loving it now for almost every episode of this paper,
I get comments saying caraway, and this is all great,
but when do I get to use this? When does this make it to the real world?
These questions are completely justified and the answer is, uh,
right about now you can use this right now.
This paper was published in 2019 and now it appears to be
already part of Houdini.
One of the industry standard programs for visual effects and physics simulations
tech transfer in just one year. Wow,
huge congratulations to Ryan Goldade and his colleagues for this incredible
paper and huge respect to the folks at Houdini who keep outdoing
themselves with these amazing updates.
This episode has been supported by weights and biases in this post.
They show you how to monitor and optimize your GPO consumption during model
training in real time with one line of code weights and biases provides
tools to track your experiments in your deep learning project,
their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that weights and biases is free for all individuals
academics and open source projects. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through wnb.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get the free demo today.
Our thanks to weights and biases for their longstanding support and for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.